the jurogan experience there's nothing
like that
for us for music you know like i
he just the place where you guys hang
not really i mean there was at one point
you know i bartended
the viper room for years did you really
yeah well
that's how i ended up moving to l.a i
was a
i was home it was getting really
miserable in berkeley i'd been home for
about a week from the
end of touring everywhere i went it was
an issue not
you know mostly positive but still it's
like you feel like everybody's looking
at you there are kids camped out on my
lawn
a couple days a bunch of days in a row
at least one like 100 people come up to
me a day
but one of them was like hey are you
that guy from county coast
yeah you're adam dirtz yeah you guys are
so lucky thank you i mean because you
suck
and there's so many good bands in the
bay area it's wild that a band of shitty
as you would be so successful to your
face
yeah and i was just like it happened
like four or five days in a row
i mean it was dwarfed by the amount of
people that were coming up just loving
the band but still it was like it
started to feel like
if there's gonna be one of these every
day is one of them gonna have a gun you
know
is like is this mark david chapman is
like it seems such such a weird
obsession
to walk up to a total stranger in the
line for a bank
you know and just say something like
that yeah like it was so weird
uh but we like we got really famous
really quickly and
uh i was the only people i knew in l.a
really were people at the viper and i'd
met a few of them
playing across the street at the whiskey
on the first tours and uh
so i i was went home that day i'd been
home for i think seven days and it
happened like six of those seven days
and uh i got a phone call and it was it
was sal and johnny saljenko who ran the
viper and he's johnny depp's partner and
they called me up and they're like
hey we want to invite you to this party
tonight and i was like kind of
half and half out i wasn't really
listening and and finally they're like
wait what's going on man and i told them
what was happening and they're like
hang on jack and put you on hold i sat
there and finally know what was going on
they came back and they said okay it's
it's kate moss's 21st birthday tonight
and we're throwing a party here the
club's closed
we're just throwing party not
so i available grabbed my stuff went to
the airport went to this party at the
viper with just like interesting people
and i was like i didn't go home again
that was it i moved to l.a after that it
was uh
i did i stayed at the bellage for a few
days i moved to like a bungalow at the
sunset marquis and then eventually uh i
rented this house in the hills
one the one of the bartenders shannon
mcmanus at the viper her best friend was
christine applegate
and she was my landlord she ran me this
old like
she had this [ __ ] place it was like a
little cottage in laurel canyon
and it turned out it was built by the
cowboy star
tom mix in the 20s and then it was david
niven's like in town [ __ ] pad
and he named it rogues retreat when
there was a little sign up there after
this tv show he was on called the rogues
in like the 60s
and then i don't know i i think it was
the i don't know what it was after that
but she owned it and i stayed there i
wrote
most of our second record in that place
before i bought a place but yeah man the
viper room for a couple years
i bartended all the time because it was
just less crowded on that side of the
bar
my friends all worked there so i would
be there anyways hanging out with them
and so you
bartended while you were a rock star oh
yeah huge rock
at the height of it wow like because i
was back there and i'd be hanging out
with
shannon smoking cigarette drinking beers
behind the bar you know and
in the downstairs bar they're the little
one and i don't know one point
i'd help her out with stuff and at one
point she's like i go to the bathroom
there's nobody else will you just
you know mine the bar and i was like
yeah sure so i did it
and you know i had no qualms about
berating people for tips
i'm a rock star and they're not my tips
so why not so i made her so i made her
like a few hundred dollars in the like
five minutes she was gone and uh she's
like you gotta do this all the time so i
just started going there i mean that's
where i lived anyways i was kind of
there every day
the only people i knew so i just started
bartending
every night and it was like my home you
know it was like i felt
it was like a cheers thing i felt like
okay there
it's kind of a cool way to interact with
people too because there is a barrier
and it is less crowded over there and
it's probably kind of fun
yeah and you know you uh talk to them if
you want to if you don't want to you got
to get a beer for someone else
so you know and there was just so many
people it was like what i thought
like uh the
left bank would have been like in paris
in the 20s i mean it was like allen
ginsberg coming in and
william burrows the hughes brothers all
these different filmmakers you know
musicians tom petty
it was just really wild gibby haynes
from the butthole surfers you know we're
all just hanging out there
wow john it was like johnny's clubhouse
and we all we had barbecues on sunset on
sundays
you know and we just sort of for a few
years
it was this really cool like
club kinda wow like a clubhouse it was
very much like that
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only
on spotify watch back catalog jre videos
on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience